the reason I reached out to you guys is
because like I said I was doing a whole
bunch of research on Islam man after
Andrew Tate converted to Islam I went
and did my own research I found you guys
YouTube channel watching a whole bunch
of videos I fell in love and I was like
yeah I do need to get on this stream I
do need to talk to these guys I want
some more insight about Islam and I want
to go ahead and convert and make my
journey man
may God bless you bro
you said that you you were following
Andrew Tate's stuff and then you saw him
become a Muslim yeah and then they got
you curious yeah that got me curious
because well the crazy part about my
story is my dad was Muslim too but at
the same time my mom and my dad
separated right oh I got you yeah so my
mom my dad separated
like after Andrew tell you when he
converted I was like let me actually
take as I'm an adult now let me actually
take a look back in the Islam let's see
what it's talking about and everything
and yeah man it's the truth like after
reading it I'm in love man
that is beautiful that's beautiful very
beautiful so please bro please go into
your story start from scratch man we got
we got all the time in the world and and
tell us where you are today if you have
any questions we'll try to answer them
along the way all right yeah so
basically my story starts off man so I
started off standing like I'm in the I'm
in the U.S so for everybody needs to
know that I'm in the U.S I started off
staying in Georgia and then after that
my mom my dad you know you know how
sometimes relationships don't work out
and everything like that so they end up
separating everything but when I was a
kid we did go to the mosque we did pray
and all that but after I got like after
I got separated with my mom and
everything like that she was Christian
we started going to church so that's all
I knew so but I really wasn't too like
accepting of it but that was just all I
knew from you know being with my mom and
everything like that so I mean I always
been fond of doing YouTube and stuff
like that too so I got back into doing
content creation and everything like
that so
on that journey I finally agitate
agitate like he basically I know I know
everybody knows about him man bless the
brother man but at the same time the
life he was living before was kind of
degenerate and for him with all that
money and everything like that and all
the accomplishment stuff he had to
accept Islam I was like that is crazy
like that's crazy so I had to do my own
research and everything led me to
reading the Quran man I got one right
here man let it read let me to reading
the Quran maybe they're making a tick
tock about my Islamic content and
everything like that and a lot of people
have been actually reaching out to me
and saying a lot of positive things
about them so I mean it just it's been
it's been a journey man and I think this
is the next step man and
it's a
little more all right very very
beautiful so you mentioned you have some
questions you want to ask them
afterwards yeah I can ask I can ask them
now all right let's go for it so
isn't one of you guys a revert I want to
ask you guys um why did y'all accept
Islam
um yeah I'm I'm the only reason are you
on the river yeah yeah but nah these
these sort of they're kind of reverts in
their own little way too okay every born
Muslim that comes back to Islam I mean I
would say it's a Reaper in the right way
uh but realistically I guess
I guess I am the only like actual reason
yeah uh but man
I'll keep it very simple because I I
want the spotlight to be on you bro and
right it's it's amazing but I accepted
Islam bro because I just
I was at the lowest point of my life
yeah and when I was at the lowest point
in my life looking for all these
distractions no one around me
I decided to do like a dopamine detox
cut everything out and then I started
feeling this pool to read the Quran and
once I started reading the Quran
it's just like I will reflect on it and
by the third day of reading it it's like
it all just clicked yeah when it all
clicked I felt these like waves going
through my body and I was like oh
oh that's different yeah and I hit a
fire and I was like fire bro like I was
reading the Quran and um yeah I had
these like waves going through my body
he said oh bro you're a Muslim
and I was like whoa whoa relax bro relax
like what do you mean I'm a Muslim and
they started telling me everything and
then it just kind of happened from there
bro oh okay
yeah that's good like that's exactly
kind of how I felt as soon as I started
reading the Quran I was just I couldn't
put it down like so I started I could
have put down this like because like one
thing about me I like to seek the truth
and I'm Gonna Keep I'm gonna keep
digging to keep searching until I find
the truth and I think I think I think
Islam is it so another thing I do want
to ask you guys okay about um what's the
main key differences from Christianity
to Islam because I know I know for
example um you know Prophet Jesus it's
kind of different now I know people have
been telling me that like how how like
they they were saying like in
Christianity how Jesus um life's ended
is different than Islam so I want you
guys to brush up on that so I can yeah
absolutely you know actually bro it's
amazing well it's beautiful because I
was I was talking to my brother about
this today and I was telling him no
other way of life makes sense except for
Islam and I was talking about the
different ways atheism Christianity all
that stuff and when I got to
Christianity you know I it was just it
became so clear to me that
it does not matter whatever people say
about Jesus and how he died from Islamic
perspective yeah because Jesus was not
sent for us so it really doesn't matter
why does it matter how he passed away
whatever to you living the 21st century
yeah himself in in what we have the
Bible today you know we don't think it's
fully authentic but for a Christian who
believes in the Bible as a sense today
what does it say Jesus said I came for
No One except the lost sheep of the
children of Israel right so what is he
going to do for you know for random
Gentiles living in the 21st century from
our perspective he didn't even come for
us so it doesn't really matter because
we know Islam is the truth you know kind
of regardless of what Paul said and his
other people who we actually don't even
know who they are today you know a lot
of the books were written in us or the
gospels yeah but um the main difference
is like in terms of creed and theology
is the belief in the Trinity you know
obviously not reconcilable one with
human logic two with the basic idea of
God or three with Islam and lastly
making Jesus to be a Divine figure
um he's a prophet messenger and Messiah
yeah but he's not God and nor does that
make sense for a person for a human to
be God does that answer the question
yeah it does it does but to add on to
that too like what happens in Judgment
Day like so this does Jesus come back I
heard somebody was saying something
about that yeah so as Muslims in this
life we believe that Jesus will have a
second coming right because we believe
that God what happened is instead of
letting the people kill him right he
raised him up to himself and then he
will bring him back before the day of
judgment towards the end times he will
kill the Antichrist and he will be with
the Muslims with the people right and uh
basically and and call them towards
goodness and that stuff and actually
it's narrated it would be a very
beautiful very very beautiful time where
there would be no Injustice in that
stuff on the Earth yeah and then I want
you to imagine bro like look at look at
the honor that Allah that God has given
Prophet Jesus peace be upon him to
destroy the Antichrist look at how
powerful that is and then I want you to
also compare that to how a lot of like
Christian Media and Netflix how they're
portraying Jesus to be like the soft
weak figure you know yeah it's a stark
contrast
it's a good point
yeah
yeah that does make sense to me also
um do you guys all know fluent Arabic
yeah the only I know flu Arabic yeah I
want to know that yeah I wanted to know
that we're learning okay yeah so another
thing too like as far as like the
prayers and stuff like that it's five
prayers right so if you're our you are
praying could you pray in English until
you learn it in Arabic how does that
work so
the I guess the the bad news for some
reason that you you can't pray in
English yeah but but let me give you the
good news the good news is Allah is the
most forgiving the most merciful so if
you're learning uh you know which by the
way there are reverts who memorize and
learn how to pray literally in a day and
suddenly take a week or a little bit
longer you'll learn it literally in no
time yeah
um and Allah will have mercy and forgive
those who are you know learning how to
pray but just don't fully know yet so
you'll be there very simple don't worry
okay yeah and
honestly man like a lot of people would
try to tell you like the the right way
to do this and this is the wrong way
yeah listen
for myself bro
from us although this person really
donate 99
.
listen bro like when I first started
I I actually put the um this guy
reciting Surah Fatiha and like going
through the motions like on my phone and
I would just watch him and like follow
along and like go with the prayer right
and just listen I didn't even know how
to recite it yeah so like we all learned
how we came right and again like Allah
is the most forgiving so he understands
exactly yeah where you are in your
journey yeah and exactly what you need
to do in order to like keep progressing
right yeah
okay another question I have so what's
the biggest Lifestyle Changes coming
from like Christianity Islam I know is
they praying five times a day and like
it's certain things that are Haram that
a lot of the stuff that go on in the
west is around so yeah yeah I know like
for one thing to another thing like
relationships like that can't do that
you can't do that you need to you need
to get married and everything like that
so I want you guys to brush up on that
maybe like some of the things that like
are Haram to keep things out Haram for
men to do in Islam okay so first thing I
wanted to say is is uh kind of love bro
we had this another Andrew Tate fan that
came on the channel converted to Islam
we did a whole live like shahada he
asked us or asked me a lot of questions
about Islam and him and a lot of these
people that are coming to slum one of
the most common questions they ask is
how do we navigate relationships and
marriage and all that yeah so I think it
would be it would be suitable none other
than Angel who was a river himself to
kind of talk about how his view on
relationships has changed how it's a
little bit more easy in some ways a
little bit difficult in other ways right
I mean
I was just going to say one point and
let y'all say like another point but I
could speak about that if you want
uh with relationships man like
I'm coming from straight degeneracy
before Islam bro like I'm not gonna lie
to you I'm not gonna try to Sugar Cody
yeah
um I was I was actively trying to talk
to many women but
because in 2018
okay I was actually engaged I was not
Muslim I was Christian kind of actually
yeah I was Christian I was Christian
I was Christian I was engaged as a
Christian woman and then 2018
she ended up leaving me wow now this bro
this was like a pivotal point because
for me
um it was it was very hard I'm not gonna
lie it was very hard yeah and in that
moment it's like I can't say I was close
to God yeah but I knew I knew like okay
I have to stop talking to women for some
time because clearly there's something
wrong yeah like with me not not her or
like the whole relationship like sure
she had her problems too what I'm saying
with me there's something wrong here so
I think I spent like a year in something
well I was just completely celebrate not
talking to any woman whatsoever and then
it's like after that I started trying to
actively look for him and not getting a
lot of the best planners none of that
worked out right it's like a lot kept me
celibate so that I could learn so I
could actually grow and heal from
everything and then when I became Muslim
then Allah like made everything clear to
me it's like look this is why you know
this was going here this is why this
didn't happen here and this is why this
huge he was basically preparing me for
this because
had I experienced the degeneracy before
going into Islam maybe that might not
have been the best thing for me yeah but
I know that when I came into Islam like
it was very it was very understandable
like oh yeah you don't actually have
relations with a woman before you get
married because if you do
it blinds you to the red flags yeah that
could possibly be there right yeah
exactly though so I mean for me that was
like the biggest thing in terms of
relationships
um but the biggest thing that I wanted
to say like I'd say the biggest change
that I've been singing or that I had to
make in my lifestyle
was um
just constantly constantly going to a
law rule yeah definitely going to God
yeah
because I'm not the bash any Christian
or anything like that but that was one
thing that I didn't like it was because
most Christians that I knew they only
went to God when when they needed
something it was never a thing to wear
that you call on the law all the time it
was never that it was never there yeah
yeah and that's it man that's it bro
for me there's way more but I want to
keep it simple I want to let the other
brother speak here yeah and I wanted to
touch on this beautiful point there that
as Muslims we're not shy from intimacy
bro we don't have any weird rules like
you want to get up in the church you got
to devote yourself to God you're
celibate none of this man-made stuff you
can have one wife and if you can treat
them equal you can have more than one
wife right up to four right
um but the main message is we're not shy
from intimacy the prophet peace be upon
him he went to the youth you know the
shabab and he told them that all of you
guys if you have the ability to get
married get married you know but if you
can't gun fast
um so in Islam we're not shy about
marriage or intimacy or anything like
that but we have a permissible way and
an obviously a non-impermissible way
right so that's really it bro so the
advice is obviously if you can get
married to get married
um but that's all I'm gonna say bro and
let me actually slide back in here
yeah bro when you when you are
worshiping Allah and you are getting
closer and closer to Allah right
and he puts a woman in your life
that is almost like a direct reflection
of you like y'all are on the same level
y'all both growing and y'all like on the
same y'all been leveling up y'all at the
same level right bro it's something else
like nothing no other woman that I've
ever met in my life yeah compares to my
wife right now bro right and that's
that's a beautiful thing bro and again
like I do not believe that I could have
ever experienced this had I not been
Muslim had I not been getting closer to
Allah yeah
yeah that does make sense man that makes
a lot of sense that's all I'm starting
to see man the more more information I
get the more it makes sense to me and I
mean if y'all have nothing else for me I
think I'm ready
and let me let me ask you a quick
question bro are you single yeah
there's a lot of technical a little bit
more techie cases when you when you deal
with Christians you know let's say they
accept Islam they become Muslim they
open their eyes to the truth right but
let's say they're married they have a
wife so now you know we got to give dawa
to the wife uh they gotta and inshallah
become Muslim and then you know you guys
get married but for you it's it's almost
a blessing that you are single so yeah
just you and now you can worry about you
know finding the other half inshallah
yeah yeah absolutely inshallah so just
before we get started first I want to
give a brief note for myself it's I want
to say first of us it's beautiful that
you're already concerned with what is
Haram yeah and I want you to as you
learn about these things after you
become Muslim you start practicing I
want you to First learn about why these
things are important right no why should
you be concerned with what's Halal right
you know these these beliefs are
fundamental you know oh God God says
this is halal this is Haram why do I
obey God in these regards right it's
because God is all knowing god is all
wise he created you and me the universe
and life and death to test who was good
indeed we know that anything God tells
us to do is good and anything God tells
us not to do that thing would have been
bad for us and understanding those
things makes it a lot easier to
understand you know and to understand
why you're doing them why you're
avoiding them and it makes it easier to
practice those things right so
with that being said I have to ask you
some questions just so we know that you
know you understand Islam correctly
nobody's misinformed you and all that
stuff okay so and they're really simple
though I'm not going to give you your
questions I promise okay so do you
believe that there's one God worthy of
worship with no Partners or Associates
or Sons or daughters yes perfect do you
believe in the Angels yes do you believe
in the prophets and Messengers that God
sent yes do you believe in the books and
the Revelation that God has sent with
His prophets and Messengers yes do you
believe in destiny that God has a Divine
Destiny for all of us yes and you
believe in the day of judgment yes
perfect do you believe that the Quran is
the unchanged word of Allah yes I do
perfect
and with that being said you're going to
inshallah repeat after me first I wanna
I wanna ask you guys
if
if you if you want to do it this way
so can you guys see my screen right now
yeah so I can highlight the words so you
can see them as we say them do you want
to do it that way yeah yeah that works
okay so just repeat after me
a shadow a shadow
and la and LA ilaha illallah
Muhammad
rasool rasul Allah Allah
now just repeat after me in English I
bear witness I bear witness that there
is none worthy of worship that there is
now worthy of worship except for Allah
except for Allah and I bear witness and
our bear witness that the prophet
Muhammad that the prophet Muhammad is
the final messenger and prophet of God
it's a fan of messenger and prophet of
God
our brother in Islam and everybody warm
welcome to our brother in Islam may
Allah bless them
feel good boy
feel good
that's what's up man Allah bless you bro
it's it's gonna feel
it's gonna feel different this next
month that's all I got to tell you yeah
yeah
uh sveno someone made such a beautiful
point in the chat
let me find it the Allahu Akbar is
coming so fast bro it instantly
disappeared but they say wiped clean of
all his sins and given Good Deeds for
them subhanallah when a person accepts
Islam Allah forgives them for all of
their bad deeds and their sins of the
past and let them keep their Good Deeds
what does this mean
this means that any Muslim who is sinful
you know and has good deeds and whatever
but they have sins our brother might be
a lot better than them right now because
he has no sins on his plate no one's on
his plate and only good deeds is
beautiful yeah so what does what does
what what you know should life look like
now what should our outlook on life be
some people have this perspective you
don't seem like the type so it's not
about you but some people have the
perspective and the thought that oh once
I accept Islam uh my life is gonna be
easy peasy God loves me I'm good what
does Allah say in the Quran Allah says
that he created death and life to test
which one of us
or you know the ones who are good
indeeds Allah is going to test us we're
going to be tested with good times and
we're going to be tested with bad times
it's possible that you walk into the
next step of life and it's an adversity
where God is testing you
it's possible that you're a Muslim for
10 years and then God decides to test
you with something difficult but what
did the prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings of Allah be upon him say
he said how amazing is the state of a
Muslim how amazing is the state of a
Muslim because when he's tested with
something that's good he is thankful to
God and that is better for him
but when he's tested with something
difficult
he is patient and that is better for him
because God will test the person and
there's another Hadith that says that
Allah will test the person because he
Wills for them goodness and he wants to
raise them in ranks and you would not
have gotten to this point you know
leveling up to this point in this life
or and in the next unless God tests you
and I want to speak on my own behalf
right now
where I am now with whatever goodness I
have alhamdulillah with whatever I know
or my character or whatever financially
and being married all that stuff
alhamdulillah all of it every single
ounce of it not only does it come from
Allah but it has come from Allah and
Allah blessed me with these things
through a difficulty through a hardship
and it's only been through these
hardships but Allah has really blessed
me in this life and I think many many
brothers and sisters can say the same
thing about them and their lives
so the main focus for us is that we
worship Allah alone
and we submit to him and brother
inshallah we're going to stay in contact
we're going to say don't worry it's not
going to be like a shahada and go you
are our brother in Islam now you are sha
Allah at the moment being the fourth
Muslim here alhamdulillah
yeah yeah I do I wouldn't do want to do
this again sometimes because I'm still
going to be making content and
everything like that and I know these
people want me to talk more about Islam
and now they want to see my journey now
so I'm definitely I definitely want to
keep in contact with you guys
we're here my man we're here for my
brother
all right well thank you all so much man
how many how many lives I've got a long
journey ahead
what what's your Instagram what's your
Instagram I want to send you a DM uh
she'd underscore four five six I'll just
I'll make a group chat bro with all of
us yeah make a group chat yeah yeah oh
bro something I want to see you
you might start getting a lot of Muslims
like sending you a lot of message yeah
that's beautiful exactly yeah bro may
Allah bless them for the intention but
you're probably gonna get even more now
yeah it's gonna be them trying to like
tell you what to do now that you become
Muslim they all have good intentions
but it's going to be right now like it's
very easy to get overwhelmed yeah yeah
so just take your time yeah take it
little by little baby steps here bro
Allah loves what is done
consistently even if it's like the
smallest thing but just consistently
Allah loves that consistency bro right
all right boys I just made a group chat
all right all right beautiful
alhamdulillah all right my brother
inshallah will connect offline may Allah
bless you a message
all right y'all everybody be safe man I
hope you all enjoy the rest of y'all day
and thank y'all so much man got a long
journey ahead all right
what a beautiful brother man honestly
everyone make dot for him and uh send
only positive messages to the brother
inshallah
please guys keep keep us all in the
doors
any advice for a person working at Haram
job listen bro the fact that you're
calling the job Haram is is saying that
I have to leave it so what advice can I
give other than what we're taught to
leave the job Allah will give you that
which is better
hundred percent
alhamdulillah man
I just want to end the broadcast and let
go pray man like that was so beautiful
I just want to go make it
shall that's nice Allah you know like he
blessed us with that this is beautiful
that Allah blesses us with this with
these opportunities
may Allah forgive us and accept it from
us I mean well I mean
all right
huh
like when you see people it always
reminds you
yeah it reminds you like that you're not
crazy
you know like it's actually real you
know and it's not saying that we ever
like doubt it but it's like the worst
ones it's always there and like
sometimes like Mom waivers and then when
we see someone else except Islam and we
see like they're just so on
it just reawakens it
it like brings you right back to like
that that state where you're like ah
yeah like you know like this is real
um
says
um
Allah says when the victory of Allah
comes and you see people entering in
like multitudes entering Islam into in
multitudes of the religion of Allah in
multitudes
um then basically praise Allah and seek
his forgiveness indeed Allah
um
indeed Allah is ever forgiving of of
toban repentance so let us do that now
insha Allah
um
all thanks and all praise to Allah
who facilitated this for us and for you
guys and allowed us to be guided to the
truth of Islam and allowed us to be one
ummah one community
blessed with such a beautiful Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings of Allah be
upon him as a perfect example and God
for us in this life and uh he will be an
intercessor for us in the next so
remember when you hear the name across
the son say peace and blessings be upon
him and thank Allah for blessing us with
Islam and seek forgiveness from him and
not to remind you to myself first and
foremost and to everyone in here insha
Allah as well
and let's just take a second let's take
a second to
say masha'allah to that beautiful beard
that Romy has developed over the course
of two years
may Allah make it even more thicker than
it already is boy
um
and to anyone that made it here guys
stay tuned till March
2023 our biggest guest that we're ever
going to bring in alone this podcast we
all accepted from us and make a
beneficial discussion for them I mean
and with that being said
Muslims in Norway are now establishing a
Masjid and dawah Center to enhance the
Norwegian dawa if you donate to the
schools you will ensure Allah reap the
rewards thousands of Muslims coming back
to Islam and many of those who become
Dwight and invite Islam so click the
link and donate now and share the video
for extra reward